[Music]
what did you do this weekend ina me
nothing very interesting the world
remains in mourning after the death of
the Superman evacuate what we're laying
over there no Spencer those Montanans
animals and where is the god of math the
math vigilante has been a no-show
they said the Age of Heroes could never
come again pastel we don't have anymore
time
[Music]
I'll protect issue
no lanterns
[Music]
kotomi
it's really for
chuckles one this is the days or months
biggest concerns were exploding windup
penguins this is crazy cause birthing
rorg and I each other in some way is
held back
don't engage alone Little Miss together
we'll call you ain't ready to do battle
relax Alfred I'll take it from here
uh do I know you
Superman was a beacon to the world it
into saved people and you can see the
best parts of the south
oh I've been recognized as well we all
have to recognize
we just have to drive it
[Music]
how many of you are there not enough
you're really pitiful oh wow they just
they really just vanish
oh that's rude
[Music]
you said you'd come now let's hope
you're not too late
happy comic-con week continues everybody
new Justice League let's break it down
and there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber we have a
comment on this video I know you're all
freaking out about all this Batman rumor
stuff I'll address that at the end of
this video we need to freak out about
footage first we get to see Steppenwolf
for the first time we get that teaser
for Superman at the end so I think they
did the right thing in not showing
Superman even though we know he's coming
back let's just hope that you're not too
late I love all the Jason Momoa
one-liners - he skateboards a parademon
down through a building you get a real
sense for the color of the film -
compared to previous DC movies Wonder
Woman was a good example even though it
was developed completely separately from
what the Justice League movies are doing
it's really is a continuation of Batman
V Superman even though they all exist in
the same universe so just a reminder
this is Zack Snyder's film so like
everything you're seeing here is his
vision even though joss whedon is
pushing the movie over the finish line
but it just looks absolutely fantastic
you get to see more of cyborg in action
we haven't seen that much footage of him
don't worry Alfred I'll take it from
here is he hacks into Batman's
wall-crawler
I love the intro to like you just don't
walk up and punch Wonder Woman in the
back of the head with a gun it is only
going to make her matter probably most
interesting detail in addition to all
this cool Steppenwolf footage is the
fact that he is summoned by the
Amazonian mother box the one that they
keep on Thomas Kira that we did not see
during the Wonder Woman movie that was
actually there during that they just
chose not to show it because that's more
of a Justice League thing so back to
famous Kira I believe there's also going
to be something of a flashback to famous
Kira too because they'll explain how
they came into possession of the mother
boxes to begin with in Ben Affleck I
know a lot of you are wondering about
his future in the DC EU here's a clip of
him saying that that's basically
bullcrap like he's happy to play the
character
[Applause]
yes I'm so thrilled to do that
interaction together to jest about it's
[ __ ] amazing and to build a new habit
is to discreetly on you know Kenneth
tsujihara to grow little member is said
to be willing to be our Batman and you
know I believe in Matt Reeves doing it
like I would be a from the ground from a
tree some of my team at so I'm really
blown away and excited and it's a great
time in the DC Universe introducing some
stuff from just see why so if it wasn't
clear he's implying that he's happy to
play a background a band Matt Reeves
movies so that means he's really down to
be Batman in Matt Reeves Batman movie
people were just wondering is he going
to be the Batman in the future it sounds
like he will we'll check back in when
they get to Justice League to they made
a whole bunch of announcements about the
other movies we finally learned about
the flash movie it's going to be a
flashpoint movie in all of a sudden that
Barry knee comes all the way back around
from last year at comic-con of the flash
panel this is going to be so great they
also showed off an Aquaman teaser but
they're probably not going to post that
online it was just a way to introduce
how different the undersea realm of
Atlantis and the world of Aquaman is the
clip opens with a couple of old
fishermen on a boat just fishing in the
middle of the ocean they catch something
on their line but it turns out to be
this giant ship going underneath them
the camera pans below the waves and you
find out that it's hundreds of ships you
see a bunch of Atlanteans riding actual
sharks the fishermen [ __ ] their pants
then it jumps to a clip of Aquaman
talking to a villain off screen saying
you don't want to maybe talk this out
before we start biting and then you
don't hear the villains response but
Aquaman chuckles and laughs and says
yeah me neither
and then it just cuts to black so I
wouldn't expect that first Aquaman
trailer to drop until Justice League is
released in November but this all looks
fantastic I'm so pumped up about this
let me know what do you guys think it
what will happen is there'll be a blast
season 4 trailer later tonight so I'll
announce the winner of the giveaway when
I post that
while you wait for everything you can
click here for the defenders trailer
from last night and you can click here
for the brand-new Game of Thrones
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you